hey youtubers is Charlie so today we're
gonna be talking all about mance rayder
so this is mostly gonna be a history
video I'll have a special spoiler tag
whenever we get to like where we are on
the show right now just in case you guys
don't want to talk about theories or
anything that happens in book 5 I also
have some news about the IMAX screenings
as well as my giveaways between now and
when the season starts and some of those
videos so I'll have all that news at the
end of this so just that we're all on
the same page when we start there's like
a big fan theory about who mance rayder
really is I mean there's really like one
really big theory so I'm gonna start
with that because I want us to be on the
same page when we're talking about
manses history because in order to talk
about its history we need to establish
that he has a history and he's not
secretly someone else so here we good
this is all conjecture this is all
theories taken from the books but either
way most of you probably already guessed
the theory I'm talking about mance is
secretly a glamoured Rhaegar Targaryen I
don't think it's true because mance gets
tied up with some other magic and I
don't think that the new magic would
work if he was already glamoured it's
just that if glamouring requires you to
have something like attached to you like
a jewel or a talisman then whenever he
was captured by Stannis's army and was
stripped of his possessions if he'd have
been glamoured his disguise would have
immediately fallen off and he would have
turned back into Rhaegar Targaryen like
the minute that they stripped him of all
his stuff you also have to consider the
way the actors playing the character on
the show you know could deviate a little
bit from what George R Martin intended
because the actors take you know a few
liberties with their characters but it
just does not feel like he is secretly
someone else I am assuming you know for
the purposes of this video that mance
rayder really is mance rayder
given all that very little is known
about his is actual history before he
joined the Nights Watch so that's where
we're gonna start the history he was
born to a wildling north of the wall who
we don't know we don't who his mother
was as a child though he got caught up
in a random raiding party that tried to
attack the Nights Watch everyone was
killed but the brothers showed mance
mercy
gave him the chance to take the black or
be put to the sword as you'd expect he
chose the lesser of two evils I mean he
didn't want to die it doesn't say that
he immediately became a brother or took
the vows it's just that the Nights Watch
took him in and at some point he
officially took the black the books
don't go into really great detail what
he did as he grew to adulthood mostly he
served the shadow
tower underneath Denys m'allister before
he eventually bailed he became a ranger
so that was the highest rank he ever
attained he's claimed to have visited
Winterfell on two separate occasions the
first time was while he was still with
the Brotherhood the second time was
after he had become king-beyond-the-wall
when mance was still part of the
Brotherhood his Lord Commander was
cordial that was the one before jailer
Mormont that Lord Commander traveled to
Winterfell sometime in the early years
after Robert's rebellion to meet with
Ned Stark probably just to ask for more
support more supplies for the wall mance
didn't say how old he was but he did say
at the time he saw a very young Robb
Stark and Jon Snow so my guess is it
would be sometime ten years before the
events of book 1 the second time he
claimed to have visited was actually a
lot more interesting he says that he
visited the night that Robert Baratheon
brought his entourage to ask Ned Stark
to become hand of the king so that was
at the very beginning of book 1 it means
he would have been there for all that
for Cersei and Jaime pushing bran out
the window all that stuff he plays the
lute like he's actually a pretty good
lute player so he claims that he
disguised himself as a musician to play
during the banquet that night his real
motivation was recon they didn't say
whether or not he'd already United the
wildling tribes he's probably in the
early days of that he's probably
finishing that he really wanted to find
out what kind of a person in King Robert
Ned and Benjen stark were probably
because he was in the early days of
planning to migrate the wildlings south
of the wall like he was probably still
working on that plan and at the time he
had no idea how they would react to him
trying to move the wildlings south of
the wall most of the Lords of Westeros
would probably flip their I think
that mance was hoping that the Starks as
well as King Robert would be a little
more reasonable he did specifically call
out Benjen stark he said he was a bane
to the wildlings
just because benjin is a ranger so he
ran into wildlings all the time so he
just jumped around in the timeline a
little bit so let's let's rewind to
before mance actually quit the Nights
Watch the reason he left is actually a
little bit of a twist on what happened
with Jon Snow and Ygritte he was ranging
north of the wall one day a Shadowcat
almost killed him a random wildling
woman found him took care of him till he
was better and patched him up the books
don't specify how long he stayed with
her but I mean they make it sound like
it was a moderate amount of time at
least more than a week enough to form a
connection with her like it wasn't an
overnight thing
so when he came back to the Nights Watch
poor girl disciplined him for not
replacing the cloak that the wildling
woman had fixed and that was the straw
that broke the camel's back I guess I
guess man says time with a wildling
woman had just reminded him of the
freedom he lost and so he said peace I'm
out of here and return to the free folk
the books don't really specify how much
time passed between that and him uniting
the wildling tribes but my guess is that
it's sometime less than ten years just
because it seems like he'd already
United the tribes at the start of book
one so for some of the characters in the
books we have like specific birth dates
we really don't have that for mance so
we can only guess how old he is
although he is said to be going great so
I do think he's older than Ned Stark
I would say he's probably late 40s given
that Ned is in his mid-30s when he's
last seen alive and he's premature gray
and manse's full-on gray the funny thing
about the age of the characters is that
the TV show makes most of the adult ones
mostly adult characters older than they
are in the books they do it with a
couple of the younger ones too like
Jaime and Cersei for example in the
books they're way younger than they are
on the show I mean you just have to
remember that during this period in
history just like in real life history
people got married and had children way
younger than they do now
Cersei was 18 in the books when she
married Robert Joffrey was born two
years after that so right now where we
are in the story she'd be mid-30s but on
the show she seems more like she's
mid-40s maybe you know maybe early 40s
the show kind of sidesteps this problem
by just having the characters never say
how old they are out loud but on the
show you just generally assume that
Cersei is about as old as Lena Headey is
you know five minute movie it's like a
little bit younger so let's fast forward
to where we are in this story right now
as of the end of season four mance has
been captured by a Stannis's army and is
awaiting judgment for someone who's the
leader of an army on the losing side of
a big battle that just went down he
seems remarkably reasonable he's a
fairly noble character which is why I
believe he was never out for power he
was just trying to save his people
otherwise he would have been so quick to
surrender so right now we have to get
into a book five steps so I'm gonna put
this spoiler tag up in case you guys
don't want to know anything you haven't
read the books or anything so I'll be
talking about a few theories as well as
some stuff that happens at the end of
book five with manses characters
specifically okay so here we go
mance at the wall does not end up in the
fire why did Melisandre save him
I'm sure there are several reasons most
of them practical I think she sensed
that he's a very capable leader of men
with an expansive knowledge of the north
so he's gonna be a big asset in their
war with the white walkers second reason
his blood might not qualify as royal
enough to satisfy Melisandre spell to
raise the dragon we all know she's been
trying to do that the show has twisted
that a little bit by bringing Shireen
into the plot like Shireen was brought
to the wall even though we didn't see
her in those last two episodes the books
aren't super specific on what exactly
qualifies as royal blood so like if
manses son is born to the
king-beyond-the-wall
and his blood qualifies does it mean
that you have to be born a royal for
your blood to qualify regardless of her
actual reasons I think that Melisandre
senses that killing mance would hurt
their cause more than it would help it
so has it right now he's alive albeit
glamoured to look like Rattleshirt what
I think is going to be happening in the
next two books with mance is he's just
gonna continue to give them advice as
the White Walkers descend on the wall I
do think he's gonna get tied up in the
Jon Snow plot but because this is a
man's video I'm gonna keep all the Jon
Snow stuff from book 5 season 5 in a
separate video that I'll be doing before
the season starts okay so spoilers over
here's my big question for you guys do
you think that you know because we
barely saw mance and season four they're
gonna do the same thing in season five
and they'll like he'll cut out most of
his story you know maybe show a few
things or do you think that they will do
like the very big book moments for his
character the producers have a history
of cutting out specific book characters
and giving their big moments to other
characters that they've already cast in
the show so there will be a lot more of
that in season 5 regardless of what
happens to mance when we do get to
moments like that I'll actually I'll
mention what the changes were whenever
I'm posting the video for whatever
episode it happens in so like if there's
like a big change in Episode two I'll
specifically state all the changes
whenever I post my episode 2 video
that's one of the fun things about doing
videos for adaptations is like you know
you have all the books stuff and then
you have all the show stuff and both can
be very entertaining but sometimes it's
fun to see how they change things or why
they change things so here's an update
on what's going on with the IMAX
screenings they rescheduled them for the
week later so they're gonna start on
January 29th they just did that so they
get add more theaters so it's a good
thing so you'll have a full week to go
see the IMAX trailer like the season 5
trailer
the last two episodes of season 4 and
don't don't worry if you can't make it
HBO is still gonna post a version of the
trailer online they haven't said when
they're officially posting that trailer
online but as soon as they do I'll post
my breakdown video what I'm hoping is is
that they post the trailer online the
same day they start the screening so
that'd be January 29th but there's no
confirmation on that so more important
dates episode 1 is gonna air on Sunday
April 12th they're just gonna like cycle
it a little bit for international dates
but that's basically the weekend
everything starts I know I have my
regular weekly giveaway going on for all
the bonus videos but for that first
episode I have a special giveaway it's
just like a little bit more special I
have a signed copy of feast for crows
and a signed copy of Dance with Dragons
that I'll be giving away both those
books in that episode one video whenever
I post that so that'll be April 12th
until then the giveaway will be normal
I'll be like normal Amazon gift cards if
I can find a way to I will give away
gift cards for the HBO subscription
service the streaming service just
because the monthly cost of that is
pretty comparable with the giveaway
prizes that I give away like in terms of
value so be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's gonna be a lot of fun
I'll be posting a couple more bonus
videos before the trailer starts and
especially before the season starts
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner
Blake Hutton you win an Amazon gift card
just re touch me on my channel for
details so I can get communication info
so my next bonus video is probably gonna
be another character video for a
secondary character feel free to leave
requests in the comments below
but until then while you're waiting for
that you can click here for my Qyburn
video and you can click here to learn
all about the new Marvel Star Wars comic
it's really awesome if you've never read
comics and you want to start start with
the new Star Wars stuff and marvel thank
you so much for watching so let's all
high-five I will see you guys tonight
[Music]
you